[Music]
if you are about to go on a plane or are
just curious to know how to face
stressful situations this video could
change your life forever from choosing
the safest seats to avoiding the worst
life-threatening situation make sure you
stay onboard until the end to have more
chances to survive if this is your first
time visiting our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 ways you can survive a plane crash
the risk the last thing that you want to
do is be too anxious whether you plan to
travel soon or just can't stop thinking
about how your life is going to end the
best way to survive is to be focused and
you don't want negative thoughts to keep
you from thinking properly anxiety won't
help anyone so the first thing to do is
take a deep breath and think about all
the reasons why you don't have to worry
air travel is the safest way to travel a
long distance as there are fewer
accidents per miles traveled compared to
other modes of transport the odds of a
plane crash are 1 in 11 million
according to an instructor at Harvard
University traveling by car is ten times
more dangerous and most of us don't even
mind doing it every day and even if your
plane crashes the odds are in your favor
over 90% of passengers whose plane
crashed in the United States survived
according to a US government study even
on the worst plane crash more than half
of the passengers and the crew survived
and you can be one of them if you are
lucky enough and listen to our basic
survival tips if you're still too
anxious
we recommend talking to your physician
about how you are feeling in the hope
that they will help you find a better
way to feel safe on board and even if
your plane doesn't crash you'll be happy
to be able to enjoy the trip the safest
seats one of the first things that you
want to do if you want to survive a
plane crash is to book one of the safest
seats the best place to be is at the
rear of the plane the producers of the
show the crash let a Plane full of
dummies crash into the desert the
sitting in front of the plane usually
reserved for first class were ripped off
none of them would have survived but 78%
of the other passengers would have had a
chance to escape
according to Popular Mechanics you have
69 percent chance to survive if you are
seated at the rear of the plane 56
percent if you are seated over the wings
and 49 percent if you are sitting at the
front moreover you want to be sitting
close to an exit according to a
University of Greenwich study those who
sat more than six rows from an exit were
less likely to survive you should also
avoid sitting close to the window
because people would be blocking you on
your way to escape however if there is
one reason why you shouldn't book these
seats it's because that's where the
anxious people are with one chance an 11
million - crash sometimes it's better to
think only about the view or the comfort
when you book your seat if you want to
watch just one more video the premium is
the platform where you should go get
early access to videos from the Thames
the taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place
without free browsing click this link in
the description below to sign up for
free to the premium and get ready to
binge watch videos from your favorite
channels the preparation there are also
many things that you need to think about
before your flight to have more chances
to survive first you will want to dress
comfortably high heels are not even
comfortable during a safe eight hour
flight so imagine what it would be like
if you have to survive a plane crash
they are not even allowed on the slide
and if you take them off you could cut
your feet on broken glass lace-up shoes
are the best thing to wear you also want
to make sure to stay warm it's better to
bring more clothes than you need and
keep your jacket on your lap when you
are on the plane the more clothes you
wear the less likely you are to suffer
from serious injuries or burns wool is
also preferable because it is less
flammable and does not lose its
insulating properties in water when you
are on board make sure you read the
safety card carefully and listen to the
preflight safety speech then you can
look at your surroundings and know where
the closest exit is count the number of
seats between you and the exit
to know where it is if you can't see
anything after the crash you'll have a
lot of time to think about all these
things before the plane takes off safety
could become your new hobby the seat
belt the flight attendant already told
you that seat belt should be worn at all
times while the seatbelt sign is on
but some internet users really had time
to waste and made people believe that
belts are only there to aid the
identification of passengers after a
plane crash the person who said that is
not your friend because it is absolutely
false most accidents involve turbulence
when the plane drops fast and the
passengers get hit on the head most of
those who were injured or even passed
away did not wear a seat belt actually
you should always wear your safety belt
even when the seatbelt sign is off you
never know what is going to happen and
there could be air turbulence at any
time it should also be as tight as
possible to reduce the potential
g-forces some people might think that
their seat belt will slow them down if
they try to escape but you won't even be
able to know what is happening if you
passed out because you hit your head
what is usually happening is that people
panic and can't find the push-button
release on their belts because they
instinctively think that it works like
safety belts in a car in a plane you
need to unbuckle them and if you stay
calm enough to focus on that it could
save your life the position if you read
your safety card carefully you know that
you need to brace if the plane crashes
unfortunately some internet
conspiracists tried to make people
believe that the recommended position
could break your neck
they claim that airlines want you to
pass away as quick and painless as
possible to reduce insurance costs do
not listen to them listen to the person
who really knows what they are talking
about the flight attendant you need to
get your torso as low as possible rest
your head against the seat in front and
place your hands on the back of your
head hold your legs keep your knees
together place your feet flat on the
floor and place a hand luggage under the
seat in front of you to act as a cushion
this will keep your legs from breaking
as they fly towards the seat structure
in front of you you can also use a
pillow to protect your head and remove
any object around you that could hit you
during the crash there are a lot of
things to think about but no matter what
never forget to brace and wear your
seatbelt this is how a passenger was the
only survivor of a plane crash while
everyone else was sleeping the smoke
inhalation if you survive the crash the
next thing you have to worry about is
smoke inhalation fire and smoke are
responsible for most of the passengers
who don't survive the crash
68% of them according to the National
Transportation Safety Board it only
takes a few breaths of smoke to lose
consciousness and this is the first
thing you want to avoid find a piece of
material to cover your nose and mouth
like the seat back headrest it is better
if it is wet so you should try to cover
it with water if you can't find any
other liquid you could even use urine
this could save your life so there is no
time to think that it is disgusting you
also need to stay as low as possible to
duck under the level of smoke you might
have heard people telling you to keep
low on the floor to avoid this mode but
it is not a good idea on the plane you
will only get hurt by people trying to
escape the plane and things falling on
you so stay on your two feet but keep
your head down there is no smoke without
fire so pay attention to your
surroundings to know which exit is the
safest you will have less than two
minutes to safely escape the plane so
you want to make sure that you stay calm
and make all the right decisions though
water one of the most terrifying things
that could happen is your plane crashing
in the middle of the sea this is why we
are making sure that you are ready to
face this challenge as soon as you know
that you are going to be landing on the
water put your life vest on but don't
inflate it now if you inflate it on the
plane and that fills with water you will
be trapped as it will be very hard to
swim back down instead you should hold
your breath and swim out only inflate
the jacket when you are outside of the
plane once you are outside try to cling
to debris the last thing you should do
is try to swim you need to stay put to
keep your energy and keep the warm
envelope created by your body heat
around you if you have nothing to hold
on to float on your back with arms and
legs extended the only reason why you
should swim is to reach debris that will
help you float join other people to
share body heat or swim away from a
threatening
ermand it could take hours for people to
finally rescue you so make sure you are
prepared for one of the biggest
challenges of your life it doesn't have
to be the last one the speed you have to
escape the plane in less than two
minutes to have enough time to survive
that's the time it takes for the plane
to burn and this is the main reason why
people don't survive so it is not the
right moment to panic and stop moving
stay focused and think about all the
things you could do to get out of there
as soon as possible
listen to the crew and follow their
instructions flight attendants have been
trained to evacuate 600 passengers in 90
seconds and they know how to do it they
are the ones who have the power to save
your life
so you should always trust them not only
for your own good but to protect
everyone however if they are not there
to help you you will have to act quickly
leave everything behind you don't have
time to bring your purse or your cell
phone anyway you need to be able to use
both hands to go through the obstacles
that are going to be in your way the
only thing that you need to think about
other than yourself is your kid many
people are surprised that they survived
the crash and think that the rest of the
adventure will be a piece of cake but
those who survived are the ones who know
that you always have to fight to stay
alive the rescue now that you are out of
the plane don't think that everything
will be easy the first thing that you
want to do is run away from the plane at
least 500 feet or 150 meters away from
there fire and explosions can happen at
any time however you shouldn't stay too
far because you want to make sure that
people will be able to find you rescue
usually takes hours but it won't take
several months
don't start building a new home all you
have to think about right now is
surviving for a long enough time for
people to find you pay attention to what
is happening around you and try to join
other people don't forget to stay calm
this is the best way to focus on what it
takes to survive if you are safe you can
try to help those who are in danger as
long as it doesn't require you to take
too many risks if you see two people in
life-threatening situations try to save
the one who has more chances to survive
it's better to lose one person than
lose bows stay in one place and don't go
looking for help somewhere else it might
take hours for rescue to come but they
probably already know what happened and
they will soon be there to help you the
plan now that you are a little bit
anxious after learning about all the
things that could happen to you it is
time to use this negative energy to make
a plan once you know that the plane will
crash your mind will freeze and you
won't be able to think about anything
this is why your plan needs to become
your new instinct now that you know all
the things that you need to do if the
plane crashes think about it once again
in your mind and make sure that you
remember the step by step on how to
survive every plane is different so you
also want to look around you to know
your surroundings and read the safety
card once again you could also think
about all the different things that
could happen and find a way to solve the
problems this will help you feel less
anxious now that you know how to react
no matter what happens you could also
talk with the passenger next to you
about all the basic survival tips that
you learned so you will both have more
chances to survive what would you do if
you were in a plane crash would you be a
hero trying to save everyone would you
only think about your own safety or
would you just panic don't be shy to
tell us what you think in the comments
down below we love to hear what you
think and that's it for 10 ways you can
survive a plane crash if you still want
to stay onboard make sure you watch 10
things you should never do on an
airplane thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]